let's take a minute here just
that this laptop here cost $10,000
what's going on guys my name is David
Tomich and welcome back to the channel
for those of you who've joined and
subscribed recently thank you so much
we're almost at 100 which isn't a lot
but to me it's fantastic news now
straight off the bat if you think I'm
crazy enough to spend ten thousand
dollars in a laptop well you don't
really know me well enough because this
laptop here is your base level MacBook
Pro 2019 model however we're gonna be
using this laptop here to compare it to
the top of the range $10,000 Apple
MacBook Pro if you only owned the
2016-2017 or maybe even the 2018 MacBook
Pro and are looking just to upgrade to
the base model 2019 one there's probably
no point for you to go out and waste the
extra money if you're looking at buying
$10,000 one stick around to see if you
actually need it for your day-to-day
lifestyle so what would warrant somebody
to go out and spend ten thousand dollars
on a laptop versus two to three thousand
dollars on the base model what are
really these core differences and what
are the differences in their day to day
lifestyle that's gonna make them need to
spend this much money well if you're
some sort of Video Editor a game
developer or anything that's using a lot
of RAM and a lot of power you're gonna
need this type of laptop at hand all the
time if you're editing something like 8k
or 4k raw files then maybe you're gonna
need the speed and the power of this
laptop but unless you're editing 8k RAW
files and even still then you probably
won't need four terabytes of space to be
able to justify a ten thousand dollar
price tag if you cut out the four
terabyte storage you immediately drop
off about four thousand dollars from the
price tag which is harming the laptop
price instantly so for most people and
for myself personally 4 terabytes is an
excessive amount of data that you don't
need to be storing on a mobile device in
reality if you're watching this YouTube
video today then chances are you're
probably not going to go out and spend
$10,000 on a laptop but you're pretty
curious to find out what the differences
are between the two grand 3 grand option
and a 10 grand option chances are that
you're something along the lines of a
university student maybe an entrepreneur
or even Instagram influence
looking to step into a new laptop which
is why I've made this video here for you
guys today I don't want anybody going
out there and spending ten thousand
dollars of their hard-earned money on
something that they don't need or
something that don't really know and
don't understand what the real purpose
is of that laptop are it doesn't matter
if you have all the money in the world
you don't really need to go out and
spend ten grand on a laptop if you
aren't processing well 8k video files or
need to store terabytes and terabytes of
data on your laptop at all times for I
don't know some major security reason
all right so let's talk about the
features of the Iron Apple Pro inside
the i9 you're gonna find a 15-inch
screen with a 2.9 gigahertz 6-quart
eighth generation intel iodine chip
along with 32 gigabytes of ddr4 ram ddr4
ram compared to the previous model which
was a ddr3 ram is gonna drain your
battery a little bit quicker but Apple
has compensated for that by increasing
the battery life just a little bit one
of the benefits of the i-9 is you're
gonna find dedicated graphics card which
a lot of the matte books don't have
including the one that I'm going to
recommend to you guys in a minute the
graphics card supplied with this one is
the raid arm of pro 4 gigabytes graphics
card and the reason this laptop is so
expensive is the fact that it has a 4
terabyte solid-state hard drive
installed now this $10,000 laptop is
definitely not something I'd recommend
if you're just a general everyday user
even if you're a youtuber looking to
process 4k files that aren't RAW files
you're probably going to be able to get
away with something a little bit less
dearer what I would recommend on the
other hand if you're still looking at an
Apple product is apples 2019 by 7
13-inch display alternative to be able
to keep up with the ever-growing file
sizes Ram processing power and
everything to be an entrepreneur in 2019
you're probably going to need something
along the lines of a 16 gig ram 256
gigabytes of memory and if you really
need it you can add an extra graphics
card for an additional 500 rollers on
the 15 inch version now the reason I
recommend to
5060 GU bytes of memory on this MacBook
Pro is if that but you're gonna need to
install a few programs along the way
this is going to take up a lot of your
space but realistically what you're
gonna be doing is keeping most your
files on the cloud in some sort of cloud
storage solution via Apple's cloud or
Google Drive or Dropbox any of these
solutions are great but it means taking
off all that data off your computer and
never having to worry about it taking up
all your space now there are a couple of
housekeeping points I want to bring up
about both of these laptops and really
any 2019 MacBook Pro if you go out and
buy one then the new MacBooks have a
feature called true tone display which
constantly continues to adjust the
brightness and McCallum's of the screen
to adjust your ambient situation now if
you're editing a photo which needs a
perfect background and you're editing in
your darkroom chances are somebody else
looking at it in a very bright room on a
non true tone display is gonna see it as
a little bit yellow another feature that
comes in the 2019 laptops is something
that's highly anticipated by a lot of
people and that's the hey Siri feature
in my personal opinion this isn't a
feature that's been really improved on
or upgraded enough to warrant it being
turned on all the time having that
microphone listen to your conversations
and also just allowing the laptop to be
using that battery in the background
even if it's ever so slightly now for
some reason you're still convinced that
you want to go out and buy this $10,000
eye 9 MacBook Pro or there is something
you need to be a little bit cautious
about because of the fact that has so
much stored into this tiny unibody and
that heat being an Apple product isn't
forced out by the fans loud enough Apple
likes to make sure that their laptops
are sleek stylish and quiet which I mean
is fantastic but if you're running an
iron iron machine and popping out all
this programming processing power your
laptops going to turn into a little pop
box and some people have been going to
drastic measures putting in their fridge
putting it in their freezer just trying
to make sure it cools down so if you do
go out and buy the Apple or I nine ten
thousand dollar version the laptop well
make sure that you're always keeping an
eye on the thermal performance of a
laptop because this hasn't been fixed by
Apple at all a simple analogy I guess is
if you're in the market today for
t-midi you've probably seen the fact
that an 8k Sony TV cost $80,000
well I remember back in the day when a
plasma TV came out for the first time
and they were like fifty sixty thousand
dollars now you can pick up a plasma or
an LCD or anything like that for under a
grand why because it isn't the latest
and greatest technology and it's
becoming more readily available
throughout the whole world that's the
same that's going to happen with this
iodine MacBook if you're able to wait a
year you're probably going to get it for
50% of the price if you have it away two
years you're gonna get it for even less
and then if you can wait for five years
you're gonna get it for about a fraction
so if you can wait a few years and go
out and buy this I 9 laptop for a couple
thousand dollars versus ten thousand
dollars well I mean I'm no financial
guru but that's a great saving straight
away and there you have it guys I'm
trying to make this video short and
sweet if you enjoyed it make sure you
smash that subscribe button
20:19 style and I'll see you next Monday